o papa
o navio plataforma que permita se juntou
à época
[Música]
[Aplausos]
em outro canto do gol bufar nada agora
se tem uma coisa que gosto faz é cansar
eu estou vendo agora música muito mais
emoção música é buscar novo paradigma do
forro primeiro link na descrição do
vídeo é essa música aqui para download
você baixar possibilitar anunciou no seu
carro enquanto seu galaxy y esse aqui é
o chade se você baixar música e esse
aqui é o xande se você não baixar música
vão deixar o xande assim vamos gente eu
acho que a música cala a boca aí eu sei
que meu mandato com vocês nós não é
porque você está há tanto tempo sem
gravar porque vocês merecem coisa boa
não vou ficar importando que qualquer
coisa que eu faço aqui qualquer coisa da
minha dedicação você mexe coisa boa só
vou passar coisa boa mas quero avisar
galé de sobral no ceará que a cidade que
eu moro atualmente que dia 23 agora
sábado tem show e viu ela nos 7
convenções às quatro horas da tarde
ingresso na loja shahrman ingresso na
loja sheshan membro shopping férrea
demorei muito a fim de falar senão não
tem graça charme lá no shopping pra ver
quais em massa manteve por que você está
tão o outro gol feito com ele qual for
feita para acolher 90 foi feita pra
comer e aí eu já falei obrigado a me
responder uma impressora tem gente que
vai ficar doida a gente começa em nós
porque faltou aqui na minha cidade eu
estou começou que é aniversário da minha
mãe é o vídeo da época na tabela aliás
parabéns mãe muito obrigada e muito
obrigado a vocês essa minha mãe você
teria rasgado o chile viu poderá ser um
sacrifício um sacrifício da minha cabeça
é grande eu paguei pouco e aqui a minha
filha aqui na minha cidade o hospital
universitário um pouco pequeno onde
acontece a mesma coisa que aconteceu não
morava aqui leonel coronel éclair é o
telefone era criança eu morava aqui eu
estava sentada aqui de boa aceitada
vamos assistir nada escutava aquele do
nada eu escutava aquela blusinha
usina do ca que vendia algodão doce eu
sei porque o que é que algodão doce
séculos tanto crianças que aqui não é
nada mais nada menos que uma teve a
minha doce é um negócio assim ia na
rápida gosta nossa votei na boca assumiu
a criança fica cega no dia e eu não é
diferente eu ficava muito sozinha para
algodão doce era doido por alguns anos
eu não sei como é na cidade de vocês mas
na minha que em bom jesus do piauí era o
seguinte o cara que rende o jogo o cara
do algodão doce trocar um saque de
algodão doce o trânsito de cachar por 3
litro base de cachaça ele passava a ele
passar do sinal né
nossa que legal estou me divertindo à
beça no meu jogo no meu celular mas eu
saí a350 por hora pra cá todos o livre
que tinha no quintal para trocar a
próton dos meninos voltavam feliz com
esse algodão doce com meninas de todo
dia um dado ano passado e todo dia eu
pegava o único que tinha só que tinha
dia que não tinha e ocorreu no quintal
as causas primárias foi meu deus sou eu
só tenho dor lindo aqui no mundo eo
algodão doce e passava todo dia então
todo dia tinha que ter ido pra poder
pegar o icc trocar por um morador se eu
ficar com medo e não tem rito entendia
que eu pedi a deus que meu pai graças
alcoólatra só poderão pegar muito em que
tomava e na toca à rodovia bonito eu
escutei o cara chegando eu corri no
quintal isso achei torno de meu deus do
céu eu vou pedir a deus que seu seja bom
e eu a mudar um dos produtores da região
era ruim gods graça eu falar muito longe
vendo mas só quatro não não não aqui só
se for treinar e eu chorando chorando
tinha uma fila zinha papel mandou eu sei
que eu vi em um cantinho que encontrei
de tamanho não podia comer amy que deve
seguir a mim foi um ai 81 lado
o time é one tomou-lhe domingo
[Aplausos]
ninguém leva a sério o senhor de algodão
2000 o dia está fazendo que fosse
resolver a chave de fenda machado
tesoura sem ponta não conseguindo unir
os vasos capilares são muito pequena e
vem para o pesquisador que talvez
possamos perder agora vamos fazer a
inclusão mais preto
o pior é o seguinte você sabe que o
algodão doce além do saquinho só depois
há que ficar redonda daquele jeito sem
saber que alguém sabe que alguém cheio
de areia antes né e o cara que vende a
mudança de pé de casa era alcoólatra
romera cachaceiro ele pegou a boca só a
cachaça em chios algodão do hotel passa
na minha roupa e tudo e trocavam livro
da meia hora de dormir estavam cair no
meio fio ou trabalhando no meio da rua
pedir dinheiro à mãe é mais ano
favorável dados tenhamos a minha mãe
cantava só pra contar mesmo é o tal do
douro e outro coordenador do algodão nos
games eu mostrei que não há doses já
rodando o brasil vá roubar um pouquinho
pionés 9 hora dia que o mundo bebia
porque além de beber muito e não escovar
os dentes quando ele não bebia ficava
aquele barro de merda ele pegava saque
na holanda estava mudando do ocidente e
todo dia como é que o negócio combate
mary todo dia eu comia tanto me viciei
chegavam perto de casa corri para pegar
o momento eu chegava até domingo 21
a reter essa aqui de limão verde daqui
rosa é que ele está aqui verde e tenso
daqui rosa havia sim em quem gosta que
eu iniciei tanto seu passado tornou se
outra pessoa levava lá na casa do cara
só pela sua pronta e taiana é um longo
tempo vou lembrar rodada de sobral ceará
que dia 23 agora sábado agora e 23 de
maio em show aí o ingresso na loja
chamem lá no shopping
se você tiver gostar desse vídeo lembra
um pouco a sua infância lembra um pouco
você viu no facebook você curta no
facebook e marcão amigos comentários
seriam aqui no youtube é que gostei me
ajude mais se inscreve no canal do píer
de vídeo e valeu
é nóis ninguém